[Music]  justin bieber got in trouble for saying  f.u bill clinton so last night bieber  called president clinton to apologize  and then bieber tweeted to clinton this  is true  thanks for taking the time to talk mr  president your words mean a lot hashtag  great guy  well guess what we learned that's right  we learned that bieber's been tweeting a  lot of other famous people lately for  example he uh tweeted pope francis dig  your costumes nailing my look was first  step for me you're on the path hashtag  keep striving  paul mccartney he tweeted who are you  stephen hawking he tweeted thanks for  being cool about my posse taking your  wheels for a joyride you the chillest  sick kid i ever met  [Music]  and finally he tweeted to morgan freeman  get well soon sir south africa needs you  [Applause]  [Music]  you